欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,第一小节我们来讲一下为什么要选品,选对品对你有什么样的好处
首先我们在选品的时候,我们一定要思路先行
你先要有思路才能够让你的行动更加清晰更加明确
那么你做的每一件事都是对结果负责
我们来看一下这个选品选什么呢
我们一般来选什么,一个是选品类, 第二个是选产品的款式都要选
你看, 比如说这个圈是品类, 品类1, 里面会有很多种产品类型, 就是产品的款式, 就是这些, 这些, 这些, 都是产品的款式, N 种产品, 我这里是一个模型图, 你可以这样理解, 那么这是一个品类, 这边如果再画一个圆, 再画一个圆, 这是品类1, 品类2, 品类3, 里面也还有1, 2, 3, N 种产品, 这里面也有1, 2, 3, N 种产品, 这是一个模型图, 你看是不是,
非常多的品类非常多的款式看着我们眼花缭乱如果我们不去认真的选品那么这么多的产品在有限的预算下我们怎么样去测试呢所以说这就很麻烦是吧所以我们在源头就要下功夫去选对产品在正确的方向上去努力那么我们的结果才会更加容易拿得到那么接着我们来看选错品是什么结果第一个就是无论你怎么推广
你的产品只有高点击没有成交, 直通车都是浪费钱的, 这个应该很多人都遇到过, 这个就是你付出的时间成本非常的大, 收获接近于零, 浪费你的成长时间, 比如说你又只做运营可能是六个月或者是一年了, 那么你每次去推广一个产品是不是要花一到三个月, 如果一到三个月这个产品都失败了, 是不是你没有什么收获, 而且你也没有什么成长, 是吧, 这是时间成本非常大,
第三呢就是你的运营技能再强
如果产品没有火爆
那么你整个店铺的总的流量就没有办法增长
那么你就没有办法体现你个人的价值
你个人价值得不到体现
创造不了价值
那么你的升值加薪就没有了机会
是不是选错品之后
糟糕的事情非常多
而且我们就是在逆风而行
这是不合理的
所以我们一定要想办法去选对品顺势而为
努力只是成功的前提
而我们顺着这个趋势去做再努力
那么我们的结果才能够得到更大
第一就是符合市场需求
这些产品自带流量
而且平台的推荐流量非常的强
而且非常容易爆发
第二个就是
直通车推广只是锦上添花
成本会更低
打爆时间更短
可能有些产品一个月或者是两周你只要用直通车辅助一下就能够轻轻松松打爆了
这些一个爆品就能给你店铺带来询盘指数级的增长很有可能你这个月五个或者是二三十个
那么下个月可能一个产品就能给你带来上榜的询盘这种是不是指数级的增长
这不是能够让你的店铺直接跃迁到另一个层级是吧一个产品而已不是很多
第三就是满足买家迫切的需求更容易获得订单
我们要去选那些客户需求比较迫切
而且是当前市场采购热度比较高的产品
这样更容易获得订单更容易让客户去下单
如果你去选了一款当前市场都不怎么需要的产品
就像你把产品卖给没有需求的人
你无论怎样好的产品他都是不会买单的
这个应该大家都理解, 所以我们一定要重视这个选品, 而且一定要把选品的思维培养出来, 构建一套属于自己的选品思路, 最后面我们来思考两个问题, 第一个问题是卖工厂自己生产的产品能不能选品, 肯定能选品啊, 你卖的工厂产品品类可能只有一个品类, 但是你里面是不是还有很多款式啊, 风格, 属性功能等等, 这些也是可以
可以进行细分去选的去主打的
因为不同的属性不同的风格和外观
对于不同的国家他买家群体是不一样的
所以这个一样可以选
另外就是你的品类少但是你能不能去拓展一些新的品类啊或者是说跟你们这个产品
人群重合的这些买家是不是他也有一定的采购需求啊
是不是也可以去拓品
去选了
第二个就是老板规定只做确定的这几个款, 还能怎么样去选款, 比如说老板确定做A, B, C, D这几个款, 那么A款里面有没有其他功能呢?有没有特定某些国家,某类人群偏好呢?你就针对这一类去筛选这些人群, 去推广这一类人群就可以了, 那也一样可以选啊, 只是在更细的维度去选的,
就好了, 你不要被这些思维限制住, 你想的选品不一定单单是产品, 属性, 风格, 款式我还是可以选的, 所以说这个的维度非常大, 一定不要被限制住了, 那么这节课我们就先讲到这里, 下节课我们再见